foreign
[Music]
okay here's an extra sin for
interrupting another one of my great
Marvel's opening hero gasm is two long
sins with your narration and this one
had a portmantle I was really proud of
that the world will now never hear also
narration lawyer Millennials searching
for a way to balance a career and her
personal life I was close to taking us
an offer this throwback to the 80s Hulk
intro but you waited into the finale to
use it and much like Daredevil it just
feels tacked on and wasted don't make me
angry
you wouldn't like me when I'm angry cool
line but uh that's your cousin's
catchphrase you hated it when Chad tried
to benefit from your name without
permission why do you think it's okay to
steal from Bruce huh Jen but you're not
just anyone you are an out of control
Hulk she seems pretty in control at the
moment remind me again how many cities
Bruce destroyed without winding up in
prison that's what all the witnesses saw
I mean the witnesses also saw Jen's ass
while she was having sex as she was
recorded and broadcast without her
permission right it's not like their
memories were a race of everything that
happened before the destruction I think
at least some folks would be willing to
give Jen the benefit of the doubt here
she was at an event for honoring women
for crying out loud they won't all
victim blame her we never find out if
this mug came with a matching see you at
the trial crocodile partner mug and I
hate missed opportunities like that but
I will continue to work here because
they paid me nicely doing what exactly
wasn't she Jen's paralegal did there
just happen to be another vacancy as Jen
got canned the female cousin of the Hulk
popularly known as She-Hulk has been
released from custody I've endured so
much news position throughout these Nine
episodes and the fact that the show
never found an alternate way to deliver
Exposition it's left me with anger
issues unfortunately I have a job to do
so I'll be channeling that rage into
cine in the form of nine extra gamma-ray
boosted sins sorry Cindy was there
really no other option for a living
arrangement for gin other than resorting
to the moving back in with the folks
Trope you'd think she would have crashed
with Nikki or found a minimum wage job
other than going back to her parents
seems more like the show just wanted a
quick trip to Rock Bottom character
motivations be damned this person's
middle name is apparently doctor
hellogencia is made up of exclusively
dumb dudes if only unfortunately
intelligencia likely has some very
intelligent men in there that know
exactly what they're doing it'd be easy
if it were only dumb people who ascribe
to this kind of anti-woman rhetoric
being intelligent doesn't preclude you
from having hateful beliefs or
franchises that can be summarized by one
picture and a question I thought you
might get a kick out of this video that
Jennifer
might think we'd send a lane for being a
caricature of embarrassing moms but
let's face it this video probably
wouldn't even make our top 10 things a
family member has held on to so they can
embarrass us later lists what I will sin
is the timing of the Deus Ex twerkina
that Nikki will use to expose Todd and
mostly because I wanted to say Deus Ex
twerkina wait a second what time is it
if it's 12 18 in the afternoon then why
is it dark outside if it's 12 18 at
night then why the [__] is Elaine up and
bringing everyone's sandwiches also this
sin would have been half as long if we
all agree just to use the damn 24 hour
clocks it's not difficult to add 12
people this isn't even a reluctant
superhero story I'm just getting screwed
over Jan would be excellent at TV since
is this who you guys want
uh thinking fans know what they want
holy sh that might be the funniest gag
in the show Jennifer Walters is a woman
at a new low she has no more fights
you're not doing a narrator we're not
that off the rails okay Jen you're now
literally writing entire sins for the
channel and you're making us look bad I
mean good should I feel Vindicated right
now stop making me feel things I'm not
running from my problems it's a mental
health break teaching people that you
have to qualify your mental health
breaks you don't ever yes I mean you go
drink some water forgive me Jen for this
transgression these comments are coming
in far too quickly internet trolls are
famously quick to type and slow to think
but they aren't grab a timestamp of the
thong appearance in less than three
seconds quick okay well that was easy
all right
am I a genius thinking that violating
your best friend's last shred of privacy
somehow makes you a genius shouldn't she
have maybe run this plan by Jen first
yes yes she should
I need a favor nice try Nikki but you
already redeemed the favor Pogo due to
find the guy who connected to gen
superhero costume designer have you ever
paid his favor yet did you wait in line
with him to get those sick new sneakers
females am I right I understand using
these trolls as a caricature for incels
but they don't always talk like that a
few minutes of social media browsing
will show you they can have to be
scarily articulate instead of parody
this caricature just comes across as
lazy which is a shame because they
should be the easiest group in the world
to intelligently satirize is She-Hulk
better than the Hulk is she as strong as
him is she as smart as him what blows my
mind is it's exactly these types of
individuals who are behind the review
bombing this show unfairly received it's
wild to me that the show is a victim of
the very thing it's pointing out so
here's a sin removal for the writer's
ability to predict the future as
depressing as that might seem I'm really
proud of us for hacking she-hulk's phone
why isn't pug or Nikki recording this
wasn't that the whole point of being
here okay maybe she was recording phone
call on her end but that just makes this
sudden drop out of service super
inconvenient and why wouldn't pug be
wearing a wire recording on his phone
since he's the one in the damn room we
showed the world
she is oh come on you leaked the video
of two consenting adults having sex
which resulted in an outburst from one
of the exposed adults the only folks
convinced she's a monster after viewing
that video or the deacons over at First
Baptist and even then only if you add in
a clip of Jen dancing I don't think
anybody could really understand what I'm
going through right now except a meal
since he went through literally the
exact same thing I literally missed that
part in The Incredible Hulk where a
literal sex tape featuring Emil
literally got leaked in literally public
fashion I suppose it literally must have
been a post-post credits scene a meal
Jennifer because of course the big
intelligencia meeting is taking place in
a meals Retreat on the one day that Jen
decides to turn up unannounced this is
more convenient than Jen not noticing
the dozens of cars that should have been
parked near The Retreat because you know
none of these bro holes carpooled also
Show Skips a flashback scene showing
Tony Stark's dad inventing clothing that
will flawlessly shrink with a super
being and how it became accessible to a
prisoner on parole who shouldn't even be
using their powers my team also
synthesized your blood so it could
safely give me all the powers you never
should have been given in the first
place how is your team Hydra or the cree
what team of Rogue biochemists could you
have quietly paid for without shelled or
sward discovering them this is not gonna
work
look I actually really like the fourth
wall breaks but we're watching this
unfold at the same time as you Jen so
what do you want from us if you've got
an issue with how the show is written
why don't you go and talk to the writers
like that would happen yeah I know
that's exactly what's about to happen
and this is me breaking the fourth wall
because I can't wait to see how future
me is going to send that nice try Marvel
but I'm not re-watching the eternals
again at least not until you release
blade and I need to pretend to care
about black Knight's origin story all
right let's see here honestly I don't
know if this is complete genius or
Jumping the Shark but it is original and
it was not something I ever expected
Marvel to do and that's worthy of
acknowledgment sure it kind of breaks
the universe if you think about it too
hard but after the time travel and end
game I invested in some vibranium lined
Quantum inverted suspenders to hold up
all of my disbelief what do we get if
the entirety of the second season is one
extended dream sequence unless your name
rhymes with sister fertolin I don't want
to hear the words dream sequence come
out of your mouth there are certain
things that are supposed to happen in a
superhero story meaning that Marvel is
not only aware of this but by including
it in the scene also appears to agree
that it's [__] and yet they continue
to do it anyway are they trolling us
because I'll give back every Marvel TV
show sin we've ever given in half of
season 8 of Game of Thrones 2 if the
next phase of Marvel actually breaks
away from this formula I'm going to go
talk to Kevin now so Jen is confronted
the writers of the show who've already
finished writing the show so that she
can reshape the ending of the finale of
a show that has already been written
filmed and released to the world but if
she's acknowledging that she's in a TV
show that still means that someone wrote
this sequence so where are they this is
a problem with fourth wall breaks the
walls just end up getting replaced with
something slightly more confusing and
slightly less load-bearing everyone has
to sign the NBA Chen signs this without
reading it as if she isn't supposed to
be a [__] lawyer why are there only
five essentially unarmed guards
responsible for protecting Kevin master
of all things Marvel also glad we're
okay with our hero beating up people are
just doing their jobs it had nothing to
do with writing a disappointing ending
to a TV show Kevin it stands for
knowledge enhanced visual
entertainativity Nexus knowledge that
starts with an n Sound that changes
everything because according to my gift
friends the sin here is that it's not
pronounced Nevin the visual effects team
has moved on to another project in light
of the headlines that have since
surfaced about how Marvel reduces its
VFX teams to atoms maybe the inclusion
of this joke is a tad bit insensitive
yes I make the decisions I possess the
most advanced entertainment algorithm in
the world and it produces near perfect
products
okay this is so perfectly
tongue-in-cheek that I have to applaud
Marvel for the beautiful self-awareness
bot that is Nevin can we agree that it
is a legal comedy comedy sure I left a
few times legal I think I made my
feelings clear on the show's lack of
attention to detail over legal matters
then I would like to give my closing
argument oh haha I see what you did
there well I would hope so because
didn't the perfect algorithm also write
this as well ah I hate thinking fourth
dimensionally but it's often said that
Marvel movies all in the same way wait
who's saying that how is Nevin not aware
of this shouldn't a true AI be learning
from all the opinions on the internet
and synthesizing a solution how is one
of the earliest MCU critiques news to
them but Bruce is supposed to return to
explain what he was no no no we don't
need to hear any of that but we were
going who introduced save it for the
movie go Jen give each show enough space
to be its own thing but also here's a
sin for being a dirty rotten Hulk tease
[__] okay I was gonna give Jenn a pass
on she-hulking up until this point
because she wasn't technically in the
show but isn't this a violation of her
parole why is everyone okay with her
suddenly losing the inhibitor did no one
notice when it left this plane of
existence
wait did Nevin just stick Daredevil in a
tree and have him buffer until it was
his turn to appear I'm so confused right
now this is a problem with having Jen
tweak the ending like this we don't know
to what extent things got butterfly
affected and the only sinless answer
would be none at all if you sign this
you go back to prison for 10 years for
violating your parole I'm pretty sure
you don't just sign a paper and then go
back to prison there's got to be a judge
involved and see this is exactly why I
wouldn't call this a legal comedy also
she got fired from her lawyer job then
she isn't a meals legal counsel anymore
someone else from GLK and H would be
right so you don't make a lot of money
and Rebecca you don't ask people how
much money they make technically she
didn't ask how much money Matt makes she
just said he doesn't make a lot of money
your witness counselor this is my son
scar not saving it for the movie also
teasing me with a World War Hulk
storyline I know marvel will never be
allowed to give me or at least that's
what I heard some nerd shouting about on
the internet I think his name was TV
dollar sign underscore narrator she
super-powered woman known as the cousin
of the Hulk has been cleared of her
previous conviction so jyn has her job
back just like that I'm not saying it
was fair but it is strongly implied that
she was fired because her Outburst after
the sex tape leak meant she was unstable
that still happened nothing about this
finale has changed that okay okay now
that I know we're in the clear from the
fourth wall stuff here's my final word
on the matter She Hulk dedicates its
finale to pointing out the comic tropes
and cliches that the MCU is famous for
but guess what they're cliches for a
reason deep down most casual moviegoers
love that and guess what again we all do
it pick a TV sends video at random it'll
be filled with is good at TV sins and
they survive this and
[Music]
or some kind of comedic triplet that
occasionally stretches into a fourth
point that doesn't always hold up as
well as the previous three look cliches
are comfortable the sin isn't using them
the sin is relying on them as the sole
source of entertainment in lieu of a
compelling story Marvel's telling us
that they hear the criticism but until
they act on it I'm still sinning it
attacking on one last gag when your
previous sin I I mean scene summed up
everything very nicely and eloquently
cliche
[Music]
so I will continue to work here because
they paid me nicely
you help me help me overtime so I
thought you might get a kick out of this
video that Jennifer
I'd like to see this no no
no the prime minister of Sweden visited
Washington today and my tiny little
nipples went to France huh
allow me to introduce myself my name is
cork I'm kind of like the leader in here
foreign
there are certain things that are
supposed to happen in a superhero story
what you just said is one of the most
insanely idiotic things I have ever
heard the Enrichment Center is required
to remind you that you will be baked and
then there will be cake this is my son
scar